bonsoir joëlle mélin merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
curve ac 1 48 % d'efficacité c'est pas
franchement brillant si on compare avec
les autres vaccins sur le marché en ce
moment est ce que l'europe doit donner
son feu vert selon vous déjà il
semblerait que les premiers éléments qui
nous sont donnés c'est que les études
qui ont été faites ont été faites en
amérique du sud avec des données assez
différente de celle de l'europe et que
les doses en microgrammes dans le curve
vox de 12 mg par rapport à d'autres
vaccins à elad messager 30 microgrammes
pour biotech et 100 microgrammes pour
modern a donc il s'agirait simplement de
refaire un réajuste âge de doses ce qui
est certain c'est que même si c'est peu
satisfaisant dans la situation nous
sommes toute possibilité de vacciner et
de protéger ne serait-ce qu'à 50% et
déjà un bénéfice quand on voit à quel
point l'europe a fait la difficile sur
des vaccins alternatif aux quatre somme
toute
maintenant 5 mai le astrazeneca se
retrouve un petit peu sur la touche qui
réduisent les possibilités de choix et
de des soignants et des propositions aux
patients qui sont maintenant très
éclairée nous nous apercevons que
l'europe a mis sa population en danger
donc même si le curve ac ne protège pas
50% il ne faut pas le refuser ce
d'autant plus que nous lui avons donné
au delà du préachat par la procédure de
tous les autres vaccins
nous avons quand même donné pas loin de
70 millions de poti de subventions dès
le mois de mars 2020 il serait
maintenant quand on vous écoute
voilà on se dit oui on ne peut pas se
payer le luxe en substance de refuser
m'enfin regarder les chèques vous l'avez
dit vous-même de l'astra zeneca
même dit johnson and johnson on sait
qu'on a ce fameux plafond de verre de la
vaccination un peu partout pas seulement
en france comment vous allez convaincre
la population d'aller pour heures pour
ceux qui sont anti vaccins d'aller
prendre un risque et en plus que ça soit
pas forcément très efficace c'est ça va
être une gageur je crois qu'il ya eu des
erreurs de communication monstrueuse dès
le départ lorsque l'on a dit il ya
maintenant trois ans il faut que tous
les petits qui vont à l'école à partir
de 3 ans et 11 vaccins en même temps
cette procédure n'a jamais été validé et
n'a jamais été évaluée
quelques parents ont râlé et puis c'est
passé dans le cas l'usagé courant
je ne sais pas si on a eu tort aux
raisons il serait d'ailleurs urgent de
faire une évaluation de cette procédure
lorsque tout un chacun de se déplacer
dans les zones où il ya la fièvre jaune
ont fait la vaccination obligatoire ne
pose pas de problème en revanche je
pense que les problèmes qui ont tourné
autour de l'hépatite c b que quelles que
soient les deux types d'hépatites qui
son maximum et qui ont laissé dans la
population des soignants une impression
de risques alors que la littérature ne
retrouve que très peu de cas avérés de
maladies neurogénératives à fausser les
cartes
je pense que beaucoup de français
prennent des décisions sans avoir les
bases scientifiques soit pour infirmer
leur jugement soit pour l'affirmer il
est grand temps que nous revenons à du
sérieux
concernant la france concernant l'europe
le fait d'avoir refusé le spoutnik
d'avoir refusé le sinopharm d'avoir
refusé d'autres vaccins vue de mon côté
véritablement c'est une perte de chance
parce que tout cela a alimenté
l'hypothèse que les vaccins n'étaient
pas si actifs que ça d'un côté voire
même dangereux
hélas à partir de là nous prenons des
risques énormes je vous rappelle qu'on
ne connaît toujours pas l'origine de ce
virus
alors effectivement j'allais y venir
spoutnik ça c'est le premier vaccin mis
sur le marché un vaccin russe efficace
sûr et efficace à 91
pour cent et pourtant les autorités
européennes martèle qu on en aura pas
besoin on se souvient du discours de
thierry breton vidéo mais de toute façon
voilà il sera peut-être homologué ou pas
mais enfin de toute manière on en aura
pas besoin
c'est totalement irresponsable je suis
assez respectueuse du cursus de monsieur
vautours et son action à l'europe et sa
vision stratégique concernant
l'industrie est particulièrement
l'industrie pharmaceutique mais
véritablement au plan de la
responsabilité médicale et au nom et au
delà d'un concept qu'il va falloir
absolument créer dans notre droit
français qui est celui de la
responsabilité sanitaires les européens
comme les états nations sont gravissimes
en irresponsable quant à la perte de
chance qu'ils ont fait courir à leurs
concitoyens
je crois que quand on fera les comptes
quand tout cela sera un petit peu passé
on va s'apercevoir qu'il y a des gros
dysfonctionnements pour des raisons
dogmatiques autant de dogmatisme à
l'égard du vaccin russe que le
dogmatisme à l'égard du pass sanitaire
qui est dans un sans frontiérisme
totalement là aussi sectaires et
dogmatiques et auquel la la la réalité
vient évidemment s'opposer le plafond de
verre il est le plafond de verre ou les
murs de verre si vous voulez de la
réalité clairement les variants déjoue
toutes les possibilités à ce jour
puisque l'europe n'a absolument pas
proposer d'autres alternatives
médicamenteuse à la vaccination
prenons là à tout le moins pour faire le
mieux possible si ce n'est le moins mal
en attendant des alternatives
on verra un petit peu plus tard ce qu'il
en est mais là il faut sortir de cette
situation c'est tout à fait évident en
tout cas la commission européenne n'a
pas été très dogmatique vis-à-vis du du
curve ac puisque on le disait elle a
signé un contrat portant sur l'achat de
405 millions de doses
on a compris votre discours il faut le
prendre enfin
aulas 48 % d'efficacité 405 millions de
doses on se dit qu'on n'a pas parié
nécessairement sur le bon cheval quand
même les négociations était faite d'une
manière totalement irresponsable alors
le curve ac c'est le seul contrat auquel
j'ai eu accès où on ait la possibilité
si on ne lit pas l'anglais couramment
où on ait pu avoir un accès en français
mais il exactement comme les quatre
autres contrats complètement opaque et
on s'est lancé dans une commande de
doses dans un pré achat qui a engagé les
fonds européens en laissant croire que à
noël tout le monde serait guéri
six mois après nous n'y sommes pas bien
entendu mais cela était dépend des
promesses intenables les lignes de
production était juste capable au jour
où ont été conclus les contrats étaient
juste capable de fournir quelques
millions de doses il a fallu vraiment
l'argent injecté par l'europe pour
relancer les chaînes de production et
ses chaînes de production se lance t en
avril mai et maintenant nous avons
presque trop de vaccins puisque nous
découvrons que dans certains cas les
doses ne sont pas utilisés mais je note
et vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure que en
même temps pour nous propose le
mécanisme kovacs qui est de dire il faut
que la terre entière soit vacciné ce qui
sur le principe est évident évident en
même temps avec le pass européens nous
empêchons cette possibilité là et j'ai
vu que pas plus tard que hier l'union
africaine s'est vraiment ému de l'ue
fait que en même temps on faisait un
komax avec des vaccins pas forcément sûr
on comprend bien que c'est pas si simple
que ça dans la distribution et en même
temps ce faux passeports qui donne des
faux espoirs et qui protègent mal
scientifiquement ça ne tient pas debout
la preuve en est c'est que les états
sont obligés là de manière responsable
joint l'allemagne qui met une
quarantaine l'allemagne reste a raison
de mettre une quarantaine parce que ce
passeport vers le protège de rien merci
beaucoup joël ménard député européenne
et ex médecin m'avait dit un jour je
n'exerce plus m'enfin vous êtes toujours
médecin médecin également c'est
important de le souligner merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct sur rt france